for many summer is the time for camping
and a chance to rough it in the great
outdoors but lately a whole new kind of
camping has been developed and is
forecast to grow glamping or lamb roast
camping provides the comforts of a
luxury hotel right in the middle of
nature's beauty though remarkably the
newest glamping site looks out on some
man-made wonders Don Dahler has the
story for the Strickland's summer
vacation means reconnecting with nature
the one thing I loved when we first got
here because they kicked up their shoes
and ranzie the grass it was like getting
on that concrete jungle and having that
nature element back in your life is
really nice here what's interesting to
me is here helicopters we are still
right next to me we are experienced
campers mom Amy and kids Madison and
Jackson decided to try something new for
Madison's 14th birthday glamping an
indulgent retreat in the shadow of an
iconic skyline each of the journey tents
either has two single beds or a queen
bed inside full electricity lots of
places to plug in your gadgets laptops
phones they're not roughing it
not exactly roughing it Peter Mack is
the CEO of collective retreats a hotel
brand that sets up temporary
eco-friendly accommodations in
one-of-a-kind locations I had been
spending a lot of time in traditional
hotels and I sort of had this moment
where I woke up in a hotel room and I
was actually in Chicago but I thought I
was in Beijing and it occurred to me
that traditional hotels are just very
much created to be comfortable but
they're not created to really
authentically connect people to a place
and so to me it was really an
opportunity to make travel more special
by creating beautiful retreats like this
one with all of the benefits and
amenities of a hotel but with much more
of a CLE connected experience to the
place Collective Governors Island opened
just two weeks ago offering 37 luxury
tents ranging in price from a hundred
and twenty-five dollars to seven hundred
and fifty dollars per night - welcome to
our summit tents these are kind of the
penthouse suite that's right this is
kind of the penthouse suite this
not your normal hotel decor no we've put
a lot of effort into giving each
individual tent unit its own specific
look and feel now there are those who
say come on this isn't really camping
these are canvas hotel rooms what do you
say to that I think they're right in a
lot of ways I adore camping when I turn
to collective retreats I'm looking for
something else I'm looking to be
pampered more I'm looking to have reign
style showerhead connected to my tent
I'm looking to be served breakfast in
this beautiful space dinner I have
activities all the wonderful things that
I want from a trip without any of the
hassle so we like to think we're the
best of both worlds are there some
travelers that just value experience
more than relaxation or being able to
say they went to this destination or
that definitely it seems to be a bit of
a trend since the downturn of 2007-2008
where people have realized that material
possessions aren't necessarily forever
but a memory will last
linman art is the academic director of
the Tisch Center for hospitality and
tourism at New York University she says
glamping is a growing trend in
experiential travel what is experiential
travel experience will travel really
refers to seeing travel more as a
process of active participation and just
consumption so you're not just
travelling to a resort that could be
anywhere in the world enjoying the pool
and the amenities you're trying to
really get underneath the skin of the
destination try to interact with local
people and get a glimpse of local life
as it were back on Governors Island
glamping is drawing more life to the
former Coast Guard and military base and
offering guests their own special corner
of New York City what's the future is
this a growth industry do you think I
think we're just at the very beginning
of experiential travel what we're really
seeing is that people are looking for
more their leisure time has become so
precious because the world's become so
crowded and there's so much going on and
everyone's so busy the idea that they
can really have an authentic awesome
experience in their leisure time I think
that we're just at the beginning of that
an experience that also gives visitors
like the Strickland's to unplug and
reconnect with each other we've
definitely disconnected this weekend
which has been amazing
we didn't hope we didn't see the Wi-Fi
passwords and nobody had it no one's
been on on their phones playing games or
anything well that's a miracle internet
though a 14 year old and a 10 year old
not on their phones it's really been
amazing 3 for CBS this morning Saturday
Don Dahler New York now that's my kind
of camping yeah exactly it's the
disconnect though if you think about it
that's the big thing because you can't
do that otherwise but I was just
astounded by those views I mean imagine
being in the center of it all and not
having all of it
caving in on you yeah loved it well I
don't say this the glamper has got quite
a view of New York City shot at a
relatively cheap price I might say
that's right